data fléau que je mets des 46 mais je me
suis remis par jean du monde 9
c'est un survivant de la rue qui est à
peine majeur victime de tentative de
meurtre et de menaces de mort durant son
adolescence passée à laval et sort de
prison pour une affaire de stupéfiants
en parlant de son véhicule il parle
aussi de l'attrait des gangs de rue pour
des jeunes de quartiers défavorisés
je vous en fais d'habitude du moment
qu'elle ne l'a pas le 19 heures de
recherches sur 9 500
pour
un retour de l'argent ces jeunes doivent
s'attendre à faire face à la justice à
la place des vétérans de la rue qui
donne l'ordre d'aller tirer par défaut
le jeu utilise pour le jeu donc on
choisit pour le fait nouveau ce que je
me sens achat de l'élite et les combes
parti bergen
l'écart est énorme entre des peines
imposées aux mineurs et aux adultes pour
les mêmes crimes c'est une sorte de
purgatoire pour gagner le respect et se
faire connaître dans ce montant inclut
justice une jolie le world qui vont
vraiment le fort en sachant qu on sent
une prime de deux jeunes
gens s'est passé pour qui tarde à dieu
de me refuser un jeune de 16 ans qui ont
forcément plus jamais comme toi moi je
considère l'arrivée en jet et chapo
guzmán
inutile de me physique c'est en effet si
votre éponge de tanger où je mets bien
où je pense que nous avons fait
et cette culture de la violence se
diffuse dans les écoles secondaires de
laval selon nos informations la présence
de couteau est un fléau dans certaines
écoles secondaires du fait de la neige
n'est pas vraiment aller à l'école
pour cause qu est
l écolier
son bébé dans son esprit françoise
encore adolescente dit avoir senti la
nécessité de s'armer par légitime
défense
dans la sacoche l'adolescente est
parfaitement consciente qu'elle risquait
une peine de détention en centre
jeunesse si elle se faisait prendre avec
une arme les gens prennent plus leur
sécurité que leur liberté ils
choisissent leur sécurité on n'a pas
peur de me faire prendre mais j'avais
peur de ne pas savoir l'utiliser
françoise a grandi dans un milieu où son
entourage s'est laissé séduire par
l'argent et la reconnaissance des gangs
de rue ou pour l'importer qu'est ce qui
lui donne un cachet de l'argent sale et
passer de l'argent sale que tu fais ta
pas un enfer aux d'efforts pour l'avoir
donc tendance ainsi que les dossiers ce
qui fait que tu as tendance à vouloir
faire plus et tout le temps tu apprends
de plus gros risque
à la fin de faire ton dans la rue les
problèmes se règlent dans la vue gare à
celui qui brise l'omerta pourparlers
avec toute forme d'autorité mes frères
du switch over de
[Musique]
rage
la haine contre ceux qui osent briser le
silence est bien ancré dans la culture
de violence chez les jeunes dialyse des
gens qui vont parler complice lynch donc
ils vont faire en sorte de ne pas se
ramasser dans cette catégorie si
beaucoup et beaucoup
dans les chansons et films tous ceux
américaine des convois du crime organisé
après des années à flirter avec la
violence bruce est toujours en vie il
souhaite inciter des jeunes à sortir du
cercle vicieux de la violence de la rue
son menu le pont rouge mais nous on
apprend aux enfants sur 10 aurait pu
mais riche le récent bond sont morts
sous commises dans son esprit
à l'instar de brousse françoise elle
aussi veut une vie loin de la violence
de la rue
j'ai réalisé qu'ils soient enfin une
fabrique on pas vivre toujours dans
l'état de stress elle n'a qu'un objectif
en tête je voudrais devenir un quart de
finale munich est ici pascal robidas
radio canada montréal